it's great to welcome to the program
today tom hartman who's host of the thom
hartmann program and also
author of the new book out today the
hidden history of the supreme court and
the betrayal of america very timely
uh release tom so great to have you
today
hey david it's always a pleasure to be
on your program thank you so just to
start with what's your process when you
do a new book because you've done
a number of them i i would guess more
than 20 at this point although i don't
have the full list in front of me
does the do do you get an idea and then
you start to do some initial research
what's the sort of process that you go
through when you work on a new book
project
um i've always likened it to pregnancy
you know
i get i get uh fertilized essentially
with an idea and in the case of this
book it was back in uh
probably 97 98 right around 2000
um the reason i bought a house in
vermont and in the attic
of over the carriage house there was an
old water stained
essentially ruined collection of the
1909 publication the first time that
thomas jefferson's complete works had
ever been published
and i spent the next year and a half
reading that and
kept finding his just raving ranting
references
to john marshall on the supreme court
and the marbury decision
so that was the beginning of it and then
you know it kind of gestates over the
over the years i wrote parts of this
into
unequal protection a book i published in
2000. but
um uh you know when when we came up with
this idea for a series of
relatively small and short books um i
really wanted to go back and do a deep
dive on this topic and so that's
and as i started writing it just became
more and more urgent until finally it
was like oh my god i gotta get this
thing out
and uh the book is now out and it's it's
a pretty
wide ranging and i think there's some
real
shockers and ahas in this book for
people yeah i mean just in thinking of
if this was first an idea
um years ago the way in which the
supreme court has changed over the
period of time that you've been thinking
about this book
and the way that it's now affecting
day-to-day the lives of day-to-day
americans has
changed pretty drastically in a sense i
mean what if we go back to the very
beginning
what was the initial purpose of the
supreme court envisioned to be
well as the constitution lays it out and
as you can read in madison's notes on
the constitutional convention
the court basically had two purposes one
was to have
primary jurisdiction uh in other words
be the first court that you go to
for things like disputes between the
states the disputes
disputes between the united states the
federal government and individual states
uh disputes between the federal
government and foreign countries
and certain parts of maritime law and
then secondly it had appellate
jurisdiction in other words it's the
court that you appeal things to
uh as basically where the buck stops the
final court of appeals so
you know if two people get into a legal
dispute and
one wins but the other appeals and then
they they win and the other appeals it
goes back and forth back and forth
the bucks got to stop somewhere and the
whole point of that was the supreme
court and article 3 section 2 makes that
pretty clear
and how has that become very different
from the purpose or the position that
the supreme court has today
well there's this thing called judicial
review which is the ability of a court
in this case the supreme court to
determine that a law
is or is not in in compliance with the
constitution which is the supreme law of
the land
and um if you read uh
hamilton's notes you know hamilton's uh
the the federalist papers you know the
articles that they published in 1788
trying to sell the
new constitution the american people um
in several of his
uh there's i believe four of them that
he wrote about the about the court
system of the
supreme court specifically and in
several of them he just comes right out
and says you know the the supreme court
will not have the power to strike down
laws
you know not quite those words but you
know it's fairly clear
but in another place in one of them he
says well maybe they will
and uh there was no consensus among the
founders on this or among the framers of
the constitution
uh there was a lot of debate about it
and it was never resolved
and so uh from 1797 when the
constitution was ratified
or 1787 excuse me 1789 when when you
know we officially became
what we are now until 1803
uh there was basically you know
the court was seen as simply the court
of final appeals
and then in 1803 in the marbury
versus mata case um john marshall the
chief justice who
john adams had put on a court the day
that he left office as a
as a slap in the face of thomas
jefferson marshall was jefferson's third
cousin and they hated each other
and he was a high federalist um so adams
and adams at that point hated jefferson
and vice versa
so anyhow john marshall said you know
i'm going to strike down parts of the
judiciary act of 1797.
and uh jefferson went nuts you know he
said you know
if this decision stands then the
constitution has become a thing of wax
to be molded in the hands of the
judiciary
and uh under this uh construction the
constitution has become a fellow to say
which is latin for a suicide act
and uh this this decision makes the
court the supreme court the most
despotic of the three branches
whereas hamilton in the federalist
papers had said that the supreme court
was the least likely to offend they have
neither the power of the purse which is
the legislature
nor the power of the sword which is the
executive branch the presidency
and so it really flipped american
jurisprudence on its head
it created such a firestorm and
jefferson was so outraged
that the court basically didn't do this
again for another 40 years 50 years
in fact 53 years it was in 1856 um
the second time that the supreme court
in a big way
used judicial review uh to when roger
tawney was the chief justice when he
decided that he would once and for all
settle the slavery issue
in a decision called dred scott and that
decision of course led us right into the
civil war
so those are the only two times that the
supreme court the first
60 70 years of america 80 years of
america in history
used this power now the supreme court
uses it in
almost every single decision it's uh
and so they really have you know we
flipped from being basically
a democratic uh constitutional
constitutional democracy to essentially
a constitutional monarchy
which is what jefferson pointed out back
in the day where the monarchs
are the unelected uh lifetime appointed
members of the supreme court so can we i
mean so to think about some of the
decisions that were made
uh by judicial review so if we think
about brown v board of education
roe v wade the 2015 uh gay marriage
decision
to sort of like a modern uh left winger
who casually follows politics you might
see those decisions and say i like the
outcome
so therefore maybe this judicial review
thing isn't quite so bad
the two questions i have on that are
number one should we be evaluating this
on the basis of particular decisions
that we do or don't like
and then number two are those maybe good
decisions from the point of view of a
modern american leftist outweighed
by other bad decisions right
well first of all uh there have been far
more bad decisions than good decisions
from the point of view of a leftist uh
from
from destroying union rights to
destroying civil rights to destroying
voting rights
uh the supreme court has consistently
for
um you know are
you know largely since the 1880s uh the
1870s you know
reconstruction was falling apart almost
always with the exception of a
short period after franklin roosevelt's
administration
uh during and after um has has ruled on
the side of corporations and very very
wealthy individuals and it's just very
straightforward
um in terms of the decisions that you
mentioned um
just to take roe v wade for example
because there's a chapter about that in
my book
and people like to point to that in 1961
the birth control pill was
legalized it was you know the fda
approved it
um by 65 the birth control
pill was in widespread use across the
united states as were other methods of
birth control and
in the griswold v connecticut decision
the supreme court
struck down the connecticut state law
against
even married couples having any kind of
birth control including condoms in their
house it was illegal in connecticut up
until 1965.
and so and then
you know birth control became very very
widespread new devices were coming out
and so by the 19 early 1970s uh the
women's movement was really really
picking up steam
uh women's rights in the workplace
women's rights uh
the women the right of women to control
their own reproductive
functions in other bodily functions and
why not and so
what the road decision did um and then
the subsequent uh planned parenthood be
casey where they came up with the whole
three trimester idea which is really
something that the legislature should do
what the roe decision did is public
opinion was
rapidly moving in the direction of
abortion being legal and
had row not been decided the way it was
there's a pretty broad consensus and
i've had this conversation with a number
of
uh you know fairly high profile
feminists
people whose names you recognize
anything you can find them on our
website
um there was a fairly broad consensus
that within a decade or so
abortion would be legalized at least in
most states across the united states and
the pressure would build eventually
by short-circuiting that in 73 with the
road decision
you could make the argument and i and i
think i do well in the book
that really what that decision did is it
created a reactionary backlash
um and that reactionary backlash has led
to the death of a number of abortion
doctors
you know the general harassment of women
all across the country
shutting down abortion facilities now
shutting down planned parenthood
facilities don't even offer abortion
as a result we're seeing rates of
cervical and uterine cancer
start to increase in these states where
this is happening
um had it been through the legislative
process there wouldn't have been a
dispute about its legitimacy
um you know i i would say there was a
similar trend with brown
in 1954. now you could make the case in
both cases
in 54 with african-americans and in 73
with women
that had the supreme court not decided
in that way and
if it did take another decade or so for
public opinion to catch up to the point
where
everything got decided that a lot of
people would have gotten hurt and i
would agree with that
but i think that the consequence
of the court intervening in these ways
is
is broadly not helpful that's
interesting so with
to take the roe v wade example
specifically the idea is
if instead of a supreme court decision
in 1973
legalizing abortion you saw states do it
individually
from the period starting in 73 and
ending in 83 just to pick attention
or right so it actually started earlier
in a sense but so there was a 10-year
period there
that you would have ended up with very
similar
uh legalization but with less political
controversy that might have avoided
much of the anti-choice activism of the
40 years that followed
that's correct because the the main
claim of the
of the forced pregnancy crowd is we got
screwed by the supreme court
um you know the the kings and queens
made a decision and we had no say in it
and that's a legitimate complaint
frankly and i would say that the
legitimate complaint for people like you
and me to say you know the supreme court
gut of the voting rights act
that passed the senate unanimously right
now if you zoom out a little bit you you
mentioned
corporations versus individuals if you
had to summarize
the gist of how the supreme court has
decided
over the last 50 years is that the most
notable way that you would categorize it
in favor of a large corporation
versus in favor of the individual or is
there some other lens that is
maybe even more relevant or precise
well the court has has typically been on
the side of property
and and power and to a certain extent
that's
a result of the the uh you know
it's basically a conservative
institution i don't mean in the
political sense i mean in the
you know slow motion cautious although
some of these decisions
uh you know overturning the voting
rights act for example
are pretty radical but um
and you could argue brown and roe were
as well but
uh you know the supreme court is
basically
that number one number two at the time
that the constitution was constructed
the hot new things in the in the
landscape of the enlightenment thinkers
and certainly the the founders and
framers were on the tail end of the
enlightenment which arguably started 100
years earlier when john locke wrote
two treatises on government um and and
said
people should have the right to life
liberty and private property
private property was a relatively new
thing at least for commoners i mean it
still wasn't a thing for women or people
of color in fact it wasn't a thing for
women until the 1970s in the united
states in 1973 i had to co-sign my
wife's
application for a credit card because
women were not allowed to have them in
their own names
without their husbands for father's
permission but
um you know in in any case for white men
property rights was a big deal in the
1600s that you know
that the king no longer owned your
underwear and your wife and your house
and everything else
and um by the 1700s by the 1770s
property rights were pretty much
accepted but like it was the new thing
that
and and human rights civil rights which
is what the bill of rights was
but there was no consideration of the
rights of the environment because the
environment seemed to be vast and
limitless and you know who cares how
much junk goes into the rivers it
doesn't matter
and that's one of the problems that we
have to uh
to address right now and is being
addressed in part by this juliana case
before the supreme court which
which is also mentioned in the book and
if i could just close the loop on our
earlier conversation
about uh judicial review after
after jefferson went nuts about the
marbury decision
uh one of his friends and i'm i'd have
to look at my own book and see who wrote
the letter to him i think it might have
been john
it might have been mr mason but
in any case one of his friends wrote a
letter saying if if you don't think that
the supreme court
should be the arbiter of what is
constitutional and what is not
constitutional who should be and
jefferson wrote back and said the people
themselves
and and then and then he explained and
by the way that phrase
is the title of a book by larry kramer
the former dean of the uh stanford law
school
that is a brilliant critique of judicial
review um
the point and people will say to me well
what if congress passed a law saying
that if you
if you uh speak ill of the president he
can put you in prison
isn't that a clear violation of first
amendment rights of free speech
and shouldn't the supreme court
intervene immediately
and my answer is the same as jefferson's
answer was in 1804
is that in 1798
john adams passed just that law the
alien sedition act
and the day that he signed that law he
put ben franklin's grandson benjamin
franklin bach
who published a newspaper in
massachusetts called the aurora put him
in prison
and in prison for writing an op-ed in
which benjamin franklin bach said that
john adams was quote
or there's a paraphrase but it's close
to an exact quote old
toothless aquarius and balding
a fellow by the fellow by the name of
luther
luther baldwin was sitting in a bar in
newark new jersey
when john adams and his wife abigail
came through town in their carriage and
they had
mandated that whenever they came through
a town the military had to come out and
do a 21-gun salute
and uh baldwin said to the bartender
there goes president adams they're
shooting the cannons i hope to shoot him
in the arse
and he didn't know that the bar owner
was a federalist who turned him into
john adams
john adams had him thrown in prison i
mean you know 20 newspapers were shut
down
um matthew lyon on the floor of the
house of representatives
got a fight with roger griswold the
connecticut representative
over this issue and and john adams had
him shipped off to an
unheated jail cell in for jen's vermont
for two years he ran for reelection in
the
the election of 1800 and and won his
seat back
the supreme court never intervened what
killed the alien sedition act this
insanely unconstitutional law the the
thing that created the schism
between jefferson and adams that was so
great i mean jefferson left town the day
it was signed
and literally never talked to adams in
person again
the thing that fixed that was the
election of 1800
it was the people themselves so
ultimately either
and this is what jefferson was arguing
either we believe in democracy or we
don't
if we want to try and create a
constitutional monarchy
then yeah make make the monarchs the
supreme court justices it's better than
a hereditary family
and give them final say over everything
but if you want to have an actual
constitutional
democracy then the people have to be the
ones who make the decisions
the book is out today it's called the
hidden history of the supreme court and
the betrayal of america i was lucky
enough to get an
early copy we've been speaking with the
book's author tom hartman
tom so great to have you on today thank
you david great talking with you